where i kind of imagined that maybe
some people would be excited to have a
conversation about the automation of
jobs and technology and ai
and some people might even be
interested in or excited by
by my being the first asian-american man
to run for president as a democrat like
some people who really love
to talk about the firsts in various
categories and
neither of those things was true
it turns out that
that that what i think of as
journalistic organizations of fact did
not seem to care about the decimation of
millions of manufacturing jobs and the
ongoing automation
and dehumanization of the economy but it
was very discouraging to me that it
seemed like when i was talking about
economic facts and figures it was like i
was speaking a foreign language
[Music]
[Music]
i am back with andrew yang
andrew thanks for joining me again
sam it's great to be back with you it's
uh you know
anytime i talk to you something good is
going on we're going to launch you in in
one direction or another every time we
speak that's that's what i'm getting
used to now
first we should mention at the top that
uh you have a new book
the title is forward notes on the future
of our democracy which is
essentially your
memoir of being a presidential candidate
which is very
had to be a fascinating experience and
um it comes across in the book
and then you're basically your pitch for
the ways in which we can change our
politics and the and the role for the
forward party uh in that conversation
and so i think we'll we'll save that
that final piece for the end but um
let's talk about the the nature of the
problem you say
very early in the book that um democracy
itself is losing legitimacy so much of
the book is a look at the ways in which
our system is broken and this brokenness
relates to politics it relates to the
media
it relates to a fundamental distrust in
institutions that is now
spreading to catastrophic effect
and it also relates to the issue that
really launched your
presidential run which is the is a
growing concern around inequality you
know you know wealth inequality
in particular as as you wanted to
address by
ubi but also with respect to education
and health care and
other variables so i think there's
really three problems we could talk
about before we start getting into
solutions politics you know two-party
politics
the media and
inequality in general and i thought we
could just kind of track through them
and get your view on them as a candidate
maybe in both as you know in your
presidential run and
i'd be interested to hear how
the run for mayor of new york
was a different experience
so let's start with politics what was it
like to run
for president and what was it like let's
take it from the beginning i know we've
talked about this a little bit but
i mean your book is so interesting on
this point
what was it like to
do this
when no one knew who you were i mean
that would and for the longest time that
was the case
so i mean at the outset it seems like a
completely
quixotic enterprise to declare your
candidacy for the presidency and you
know the reactions of friends and people
uh who
would support you uh out of some prior
relationship without any
expectation that you could possibly get
anywhere yeah take us back to that to
the beginning
sure i do tell some fun stories in the
book about how i'd go to my son's
birthday party and another dad would say
oh what do you do and then i didn't want
to say i'm running for president because
i would have seemed crazy
right so i i would say
i'm in policy or i'm an author then my
evasiveness would often not work and
then i'd wind up saying i'm actually
running for president now and then we'd
have a 30-minute conversation about that
and at the end of it they would not sign
up to volunteer for my campaign they'd
be like oh that's really interesting
good luck with that so you you can
imagine why i wouldn't really want to
have that conversation over and over
again yeah and
during that time
i'm so grateful to you sam because you
and i sat down for a conversation like
this one and
your
podcast really launched my campaign in
multiple ways one the people who
listened
decided to take an interest in my
campaign and and supported and donated
uh which i was incredibly grateful for
but then this
iowan who was organizing something
called a wingding was a huge fan of
yours
and decided to invite me to iowa to
speak in 2018 on the basis of our
conversation
so
you were
a better friend to me than a lot of
others despite the fact that at that
point we were
still
just you know getting to know each other
and you said something to another
journalist that i really appreciated you
said well you know i don't know andrew
that well but he seems like a fairly
normal fellow who just decided to ruin
his life by running for
president i heard that i was like oh i'm
so glad that came through
but the er the early months of the
campaign were like that where i had a
vision for what the campaign could be
and uh that vision slowly started to
grow thanks to people like you and the
people who worked on my campaign yeah
this this is one of the the points you
make in the book which um
was a genuine surprise
for me i mean it shouldn't have been
i've certainly noticed this process i
mean it was it was all on the surface
but until you pointed it out i was
someone
who along with i think most people
assumed that there is a kind of
egocentricity and narcissism and
just search for ego gratification that
is
informing
many presidential runs
and
i mean that may be the case in
certain candidates but
what you make clear again which really
should not have been surprising but you
you make it so vividly clear in
discussing
the experience of marianne williamson
and joe sestak
that the process for most people unless
you you already happen to be a
front-runner for some reason or another
the process is just ego annihilating
uh maybe
you talk about that yeah you show up my
first trip to new hampshire
there were literally two people there
waiting for me maybe one and one person
just happened to be there and politely
pretended they were there for me
and that was an entire day
i went to a rally in iowa labor day in
2018 that drew
12 people maybe and none of them were
there for me either
and these were
everyday occurrences and keep in mind at
this point
though i was a very very anonymous
presidential candidate you know i'd
still done some things in my life
like i'm still like a person who
like values his time and you know has a
family and stuff so you would do things
all the time
that weren't positively reinforcing and
the the media
as i write in the book is a huge part of
this dynamic where the media will
completely
sideline you if you're
not one of the major candidates and when
they do mention you they will mock you
it really is the way it goes as happened
with
many other candidates and happened to me
to some measure
and so when you talk about the problems
i outline in the book
the media gauntlet was such a huge part
of running for president and i'm now
convinced that that's core to our
problems like it's core to why we can't
seem to
make any real progress
[Music]
all right let's face it guys taking
trips to the post office is probably not
how you want to spend your time and
that's why we recommend mailing and
shipping online at stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer send
letters ship packages and pay a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups
and more and stamps.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours
and tons of money so with stamps.com you
get the services of the post office and
ups
all in one place i love it because i
always forget to either buy stamps or
don't even think about it and i'm like
oh crap what do i do go to stamps.com
bang it's right there super simple easy
you can do it from anywhere you are
because we travel a lot ship stuff
extremely conveniently so here's the
deal stop wasting time going to post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts so just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
yang that's stamps.com promo code yang
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
[Music]
if memory serves you weren't mocked
so much and when i think about the
mocking part i do think about marianne
williamson who as you point out in her
own
life you know had a you know a very
successful career
lots of people loved her she made a lot
of money she had a very big platform
she ran a successful charity but she's
she's very accomplished in her world i
mean you might
not agree with her metaphysics in the
end but
she really had a a very comfortable life
that you know she didn't need to screw
up
and then she runs for
the presidency
and is immediately
framed as a kind of
and it's um
i think you could have predicted it with
something like 100 certainty that that
would have happened but
that version happens but then they're
they're the people who have
have a fair amount of gravitas in terms
of their biographies where there's
there's no obvious
joke to make at their expense
but they're just utterly ignored by the
media and and for you you kind of you
fell
more into that bin and and there were
there were some egregious i mean
the example maybe say something about
joe sestak for a second because you know
i wrote in the margin of your book when
you mentioned him i i literally wrote
who a question mark because i i have
never heard of jose right
so did you then google it but look him
up no i i haven't yet i'm a blank slate
with her apart from what i read in your
book he's got you know
give me a little color on on joe for a
second
joe as a phd from harvard
was an admiral in the u.s navy
was entrusted with thousands of lives
and was a two-term member of congress
from pennsylvania so he's a very very
serious person who had spent decades in
service
and had put his life on the line for the
country
when he decided to run for president it
was like
he didn't exist and it was somewhat
mystifying
i spent time with joe so that's another
thing that happens on the trail sam is
that i have hung out
with
virtually all of the other candidates
in union halls and
people's
driveways and at the fair and the steak
fry so you do get a sense of people and
i have spent time with joe and marianne
and
uh many others but joe's a great guy a
great man a real patriot
he does have a lot of gravitas where
he's commanded thousands of people
the media treated him like a non-entity
and because he's a committed individual
he even walked across the state of new
hampshire as a way to try and generate
attention for his campaign completely
ignored and when it was mentioned it was
mentioned as kind of a look at the crazy
person sort of thing i thought that was
deeply unfair because you know again if
you look at joe's record he's a very
serious individual
who should have been
uh given a fair hearing
yeah and in your case there were
was um
some fairly stark
and egregious
efforts to ignore you
literally like like fundraising great if
memory serves there were like
fundraising graphics where like you know
showing the candidates who had
raised a certain amount of money or
gone up in the polls enough to make
debates and you were left out where
people who had raised less money and
were ranked lower than you were left in
the graphics
this happened most on msnbc
how much of this i think you uncovered
at one point that there was a policy
that
you should just not be talked about
you know how much of this was
inadvertent and how much of it was
actually an explicit effort to
disappear your campaign
it happened consistently enough where
you really could not chalk it up to
neglect or
incompetence or
admission i think the exact count was a
dozen times
and uh we heard later from a producer
ariana picari who was at msnbc during
that time that she was given a list of
candidates not to ever invite on the
show or interview and i was on that list
so there was definitely a decision made
at some point and if you wanted to
hypothesize you know i i believe that
there is an ownership structure at msnbc
where you could draw a pretty direct
line to people who were backing joe but
at the time i tried to give them the
benefit of the doubt and it was only
later in the campaign when i had just
gone through a debate that msnbc had
moderated where they clearly wanted
nothing to do with me where i decided to
say look like i'm not going to appear on
msnbc unless they start actually
treating us fairly and at that point
they
completely omitted any mention of me
from the race for the following month
plus
during really the final stretch of the
campaign so it was an important time
it was most dark when i actually made
the seventh debate stage which was a
very significant piece of news i was the
last
non-white candidate to make the debate
stage and msnbc decided not to mention
that even though that was uh mainstream
news for just about everybody
so
there's gonna be more to say about the
media in a minute because it's just an
enormous problem
on many fronts now but going back to
your presidential run
before
well really at any point wha what was
the most surprising
part about this process to you i mean
you must have had some expectations of
what it would be like
in in what ways were those expectations
violated it was around
my treatment by certain types of
institutions where i kind of imagined
that maybe
some people would be excited to have a
conversation about the automation of
jobs and technology and ai and some
people might even be interested in or
excited by
by my being the first asian american man
to run for president as a democrat like
some people who really love
to talk about the firsts in various
categories and
neither of those things was true
it turns out that
that that what i think of as
journalistic organizations of fact did
not seem to care about the decimation of
millions of manufacturing jobs and the
ongoing automation and dehumanization of
the economy and what it made me realize
sam and made me more grateful to
thinkers like you
is that there is a particular
discourse and language in media there's
a particular discourse in language and
politics
and
they aren't the discussion of fact in
the way that you'd hope and i thought
they were going in
and so
my relative
success and performance ended up being
based upon all of these behaviors and
adaptations that i adopted
in order to
try and compete but it was very
discouraging to me that it seemed like
when i was talking about economic facts
and figures it was like i was speaking
uh a foreign language yeah so yeah
that's something that you go through in
the book as well i mean just the hacks
you found for
a system that really didn't care to hear
from you on substantive issues
but what could be
exploited by a dance video
or a workout video what did you begin to
think i guess what do you think now
about this system
by which we pick our leaders
right i mean it's just i mean we're
going to get into the the political
reforms you
you recommend but
it's just it had to be bizarre
to see that the way to get traction i
mean the the the classic moment of this
from years past which has been much
remarked upon but like the moment
where you know hillary clinton's
campaign was transformed when she shed a
tear and a diner
over whatever it was you know it's like
the fact that the attention of the media
can be swung
by i guess the human interest component
of a story without any substance and
it really can't be swung by substance it
seems
yes it i characterize it as a reality tv
show at one point during the debates
but there are
narratives and characters that the media
in particular is interested in enhancing
and elevating
and
that's really the crux of the
coverage in my case my leaning into
humor or
physical activities or
whatever it was
uh ended up
being
positive in terms of our coverage and
the energy but ezra client said
something about how we're collapsing
systemic issues into personalized
narratives and i i think that's like a
reasonable characterization of a lot of
the political coverage
though there is a real agenda behind a
lot of it uh where the the media
just decides to
elevate certain characters and ignore
others i think ignore is their main
weapon of choice when they want someone
not to get anywhere
i think
uh and then kind of
like slightly
mocking snide ridicule might be like
their second weapon of choice
and then among the approved characters
then they'll
constantly be trying to
characterize people and talk about
something
around their
relationships behavior emotions one
thing that happened to me a lot on the
trail and this is very true of this
process is they are constantly digging
for vulnerability
99 times out of 100 if they find a
vulnerability
it's not going to be good for you
[Laughter]
like they're not going to be like oh
this person's really human and
vulnerable isn't that nice they'd be
like oh look at this
so that that's one of the things that
unfortunately makes politicians into
automatons over time
so how is running for mayor of new york
different
i mean one is a different office
although
you know unlike most uh mayor races it
does have a national
uh lens on it but
what strikes me one big difference had
to be that by the time you you ran for
mayor
you were pretty famous you know you were
not you were i think naturally viewed i
certainly viewed you as
a front-runner without even looking at
the polls
because of of your your national
platform at that point
how's your experience of being a
candidate different
it was a completely different dynamic to
your point sam where on the presidential
trail i was continuously trying to build
up energy and race against oblivion
whereas in the mayoral i was the center
of attention essentially from day one
i will say that the media coverage
tended to be quite negative or
questioning and they would chalk it up
to am i being the front runner though i
think there might have been a couple of
other dynamics and so in many ways it
was kind of the opposite of my
presidential run where where
instead of being the
unlikely underdog
constantly doing things to
get energy um instead i was like the
front runner who was continuously under
attack by
other candidates through the press often
because that was their best way to try
and win
yeah yeah and so what do you
what do you make of the fact uh that you
didn't win maybe if you had to ascribe
it to
a couple of uh most important causes
what
what what happened
i think the single biggest variable was
the reopening of the city and then the
crime
surge
in new york where it was on the front
page of
at least some of the papers every day
and that
being the number one concern heavily
favored
eric adams because he was a police
officer
earlier the main narrative was around
reopening and economic recovery and
those were things that people saw as a
strength of mine
right right
okay so let's just talk about our the
the
the political system
as it is and uh what to do about it
because i i think
wherever someone is on the
on the spectrum of of political concern
bias persuasion i think everyone agrees
that there's something
less than optimal about our system as it
exists
what do you
what do you ascribe the
the main dysfunction to
at this point how is it broken
and this is the heart of my book
the deeper i got into
the
machinery so to speak and now at this
point i would consider myself either
friends or friendly with
dozens of political figures most of them
on the democratic side because i i ran
as a democrat
but you know all of these people
and
you start to get a sense of the
environment that they operate within
why we're stuck really and so i do want
to go back to some first principles
because i've been learning myself about
some things that i'd taken for granted
but the core argument in my book is that
people will do
what their incentives demand and if you
are a political figure today
your incentives are to generally cater
to the most polarized and extreme
points of view in voters in your
district because that's who's
going to vote you back in
one numerical
contrast that i cite
is that congress has a 28
approval rating nationwide right now
which probably doesn't surprise anyone
listening to this it's like yeah three
out of four of us don't think things are
going well
the individual reelection rate for
members of congress is 92 percent so
even though seven out of ten of us are
really really sad
with how things are going
uh you're almost assured of reelection
if you decide to run which most of them
do because they they really like this
job the people that will decide whether
you come back are not
the mainstream public
but the
10 to 20 percent most extreme voters in
either the democratic party or the
republican party because 83
of the congressional districts are now
safely democratic or republican
so your incentives are to be less
reasonable and more ideological and
unfortunately that's what we're seeing
on both sides which is leading us to
this
historic level of polarization that we
all can feel
that is resulting in political violence
and could end up
being
a new civil war that ends up bringing
down our democracy as it currently
exists
i just want to reiterate your your
opening point about the power of
incentives because
when viewed from outside there there are
so many
institutions and just so many
human dramas where you where it's very
easy to believe
that the people involved who are doing
these
inexplicably stupid heinous things
either are sociopaths or
malignantly
selfish or
total morons and
it's very easy to believe the worst of
the individuals involved
until you have some
insight into the system in which they're
forced to function and if it's a system
where the incentives are terrible
even very good people very competent
people very smart people
wind up doing disastrously stupid
destructive and even seemingly evil
things
it's not to say there aren't narcissists
and incompetents and
people who you wouldn't want in power
in these systems but
it's got to be for the most part a story
of
decent
fairly competent people
incentivized terribly by the system
that's in place
that's exactly right sam and
a result of understanding this is that
we should not expect it to change or get
any better
because people will if anything the
incentives are higher
now than they've ever been and
the political incentives toward the
extremes are now compounded by the media
which at this point is separating us
into ideological camps and ginning up
support for the good guys and you know
hatred for the bad guys
and then pouring gasoline on the whole
thing is social media
which obviously is going to
reward
uh the most inflammatory
uh and aggressive
language and behavior
so
we're being set up we're being set up to
turn on each other to
eventually
end up disintegrating in terms of the
society we currently regard as you know
like a normal safe environment
and that's what i concluded from my
journey into this which is that these
people are not bad people some of them
are not great people but like for the
most part they're they're reasonable
people responding to perverse incentives
and so then the great project becomes
how can you in real life improve their
incentives and i do want to give a shout
out to you
and this is like something that is a
major theme of the book is that it to me
you represent the antidote in many ways
sam it's like what are the you know
media incentives for you i mean you're
just like a highly
reasoned individual who
who
like you don't have the same
you know i don't think your producer is
uh giving you a list of people not to
talk to or anything like that you know
that there's like a
search right now people are groping for
trusted perspectives and voices more and
more and i i just want to thank you
personally for being
uh such a huge figure
for people who are looking for
wisdom and truth really
[Music]
this one's gonna make some people very
very happy because you sleep on it
imagine melding technology and
mattresses and if those two things came
together you'd wind up with helix sleep
helix sleep sent me a mattress and i
gotta say it became the favorite
mattress in the entire freaking house
where everyone's just like oh freaking
get out of my way let me get on that
mattress you take a quiz ahead of time
it's customized to you
it's like your own personalized mattress
you'll sleep better you'll feel better
then you'll wake up ready to go
if this sounds like magic to you go to
helixsleep.com yang take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
this is the best overall number one
mattress pick of 2020 by gqn wired
chiropractors love it doctors love it i
gotta say
this is something where
it's a really smart investment because
you sleep on it every day like i i've
always been a believer in investing in a
good mattress you won't be sorry and
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com yang
and get that free stuff and 200 bucks
off you won't be disappointed helix
sleep is the bomb
[Music]
i happen to be
in a spot where there are
there are almost no incentives that
aren't of my own making you know i have
consciously
designed my life that way and it's uh
you know it's not that it's impossible
to um be badly incentivized even in this
space but it's much harder and it's you
know and that's why i'm here and it's
it's a relief frankly to be able to say
whatever i want to say and to talk to
whoever i want to talk to and
to not be calibrating any of that
against
any kind of outside pressure you know
even pressure from my audience and i
don't know how much you followed me down
these various byways but
you know whenever i've discovered that a
significant percentage of my audience
really disagrees with me about something
that's the what the one signal for me
that i need to
take
pains not to be trained by in any way
because i notice other people being
captured by their audience in various
ways
you know i just have never wanted that
so when i discovered that
you know a significant percentage of my
audience i never really drilled down to
what it was but it seemed like something
like 20 percent
favored trump for reasons that i
still cannot fathom i just made it a
point to not care how much pain i got
from them every time i wanted to trample
on trump because i just it felt
important and so it is with the equally
large percentage of my audience that is
very far to the left and hates
everything i have to say about wokeness
and identity politics
the pain i get from them i
i have decided to
take as noise rather than signal
because i it just it's just very
important for me to preserve
my my freedom to say what i think is
true and important rather than to be
course correcting based on what's
rewarding me from my audience and what
you get on on any of these pain points
and this is
this is obviously amplified by social
media
is there's so much more energy
from the haters than from the people who
agree with you
that it really you you can really get
blown around by it's highly
disproportionate annoyance
yeah if someone's virulently opposed it
just seems like the most prominent thing
in the world even though there could be
100 people who just silently nodded
yeah yeah so we're living in the system
where it's something less than 10 of
any
population can really steer
the conversation on a polarizing issue
because they just have so much more
energy so we've got these various
activist
groups on the left and we've got you
know all the noise that comes out of
trumpistan and you know the most extreme
voices
over there you do get the sense that on
many points
you have a lot of reasonable people that
have been cowed into silence and
therefore aren't influencing the
conversation and and it's just and the
media
doesn't seem to care except i mean the
media just
they just keep amplifying the extremes
well again that's where their incentives
are and they've figured out that their
ratings will be higher
and their
ad revenue will be higher if they cater
to a particular point of view and then
reinforce it yeah there was an anecdote
about a cable tv producer who said look
our people don't even regard us as news
they regard us as comfort which then
will justify all sorts of
things that you might do
journalistically if you're like hey it
turns out we're not
uh even reporting the news here
you know and the fact that you have to
take such great pains i mean you're
acutely aware of the kind of pressures
that
some of these media figures and
organizations would be under
but in their case they don't have to
you know self-regulate to that extent
just be like oh what like my people like
this let me give them more of that and
then you'll be thanked for it and paid
more for it
yeah
at the political level
what are the reforms
that you think will really
change
the system and the pressures that are on
all of the all of the the various
parties here
i'm happy to say that i can use a real
life example that you're going to love
sam
[Laughter]
this isn't my book because it didn't
happen yet
but
there was a handful of republican
senators who decided to impeach trump
and only one of them
is up for reelection in 2022
and that is senator lisa murkowski of
alaska she decided to impeach trump she
said enough is enough republicans in
alaska
completely disagreed with her
she now has an approval rating
of six percent among alaskan republicans
so this is a very clear illustration of
the reason why republicans
don't go against trump
right now last year in 2020
alaska
changed its process
so that there is no
party primary
there's an open primary where all
alaskans can vote
so if senator murkowski had to go
through a republican primary she'd
obviously lose because she has six
percent approval
but
in an open primary she actually has a
chance to win because
many alaskans regard her as
very reasonable and like her and voted
for her
uh last time
and so this is a systems change
that has dramatically
shifted
her ability to exercise her independent
judgment
i don't think it's a stretch at all to
say that they've gone hand in hand where
her
saying that trump is wrong and
impeaching him probably had something to
do with the fact that she knew she
didn't have to go through a republican
primary
and this happened in alaska
via a ballot initiative it turns out
that there are 24 other states aside
from alaska
that also
would allow you to shift to open
primaries and rank choice voting
which would by the way completely
transform these perverse incentives
we're talking about because instead of
having to worry about what the 20
percent most extreme voters in my
district think
i would then
try to cater to 51 percent of voters
which would all of a sudden
dramatically improve people's
reasonableness and desire to compromise
and shy away from extreme points of view
that they think would alienate a swath
of voters so
what they did in alaska is something
that we should emulate around the
country and that is shift to
open primaries and ranked choice voting
in the general hmm
so you just mentioned in 22 other states
24 other states 24 other states that's
right well so this actually wouldn't
require legislation this was these are
just ballot initiatives that could
open the primaries yeah imagine this if
you're listening to this where you see
our society
and
politics descending into madness
essentially
and we can fix it if enough of us get
together
and pass ballot initiatives to release
them from their
perverse incentives
there's nothing in the constitution
about any of these
party primates there's actually nothing
in the constitution about
political parties period because the
founders hated political parties they
would be very very
shocked and horrified at this
dysfunctional duopoly that we have been
riding into the ground
over this last number of years and so
it's completely up to the states how to
conduct their primaries
and half of the states enable you to
change it via ballot initiative
right i know we spoke about it last time
but i think we should probably remind
people what rank choice voting is and
and why it changes the game
what is it and where does it exist i
mean and because it did exist in your
mayoral
run
in new york i don't know how long it's
been a part of
local new york politics but
where is it and and what is it
rank choice voting is a superior voting
system
that enables
different points of view to emerge and
one thing i do want to say
sam is that new york city did use ranked
choice voting in the mayoral primary but
it was still a closed party primary only
democrats voted so that's
better
but still not
ideal where if you are republican or
independent you should also have gotten
to vote especially in this case because
that primary does essentially determine
who's going to win in the general as is
the case in a lot of races right so the
way ranked choice voting works is that
you can show up and you can rank between
one and five candidates so if you just
like one candidate just vote for that
candidate walk out
uh but if you like multiple candidates
then you can vote for up to five
and the winner is determined by whoever
gets over 50 of first place votes
so if you were to have let's say 10
candidates 10 candidates in a race you
count all the first place votes no one
has 50 which is very likely if you had
10 candidates
then what you do is you look at the last
place candidate
and you say okay who did these people
vote for second and then you reallocate
those voters votes to their next choice
and you repeat this process until
someone has over 50 percent so in this
way you would end up one
getting rid of the spoiler effect
because now you can't get yelled at
saying like oh you're going to waste
your vote on the person who's not going
to win it's like well i can vote for the
minor party candidate first and just
have it go to
a major party candidate second because
then if my person
doesn't win then my vote will still just
flow to the next person so it gets rid
of the spoiler effect it enables new
parties and points of view to emerge it
discourages negative campaigning because
if i trash you then we both end up
looking bad and then the third candidate
will probably do relatively better
it can encourage different coalitions
because let's say
i'm
a contender and doing well and there's a
minor candidate who has a little bit of
support maybe i'll take their signature
issue with their blessing and say hey
like if you liked that candidate maybe
you can like me too
so this process would dramatically
improve
the representation and incentives and
also enable political dynamism because
you can't get bludgeoned over the head
saying can't waste your vote you're
going to screw it up for someone else
all of a sudden you can express
your point of view more fully and i do
want to use another real life example
if
ranked choice voting had been used in
the republican party primary during
trump's nomination he probably doesn't
win because
there were a lot of people that did not
like trump during that process but he
was getting let's call it 38 40 of the
vote and then the other candidates were
splitting the other 60
but if you'd had rank choice voting you
might have found that
not over 50 percent of people really
liked trump because it seemed to be kind
of an all-or-nothing
affection where he's concerned
[Music]
are you a little bit down in the dumps
if you are don't worry about it i think
all of us are genuinely it's not been a
great time but one thing you can do that
will actually
pick you up and make you happier is talk
to someone and a great way to find
someone to talk to is betterhelp.com
it's not a bot what they do is they
connect you with a licensed professional
therapist who's a little bit on call for
you so you can just book something you
can start communicating with them in
under 48 hours
it's like having a therapist on call
like uber for therapists i'm not sure
i'm supposed to say that but whatever i
said it so check out betterhelp.com
yang it's gonna help that's literally in
the name
and
if you want to join over a million
people who've already started using it
go to betterhelp.com yang as a listener
you'll get 10 percent off your first
month by visiting them they're
sponsoring the pod again that's
betterhelphelp.com
yang it's great to be able to pitch
something that i know is going to help
[Music]
but one other thing to say about open
primaries is that
i think it's true to say that they're
more independents than there are
democrats or republicans right at this
point and they're excluded from
primaries that's right nationally and i
have a feeling your listeners reflect
this sam i just have that feeling
but
right now
independents are the most numerous
political group in the country about 44
and then
democrats and republicans are generally
somewhere in the
mid to high 20s
now if you're an independent you often
feel forced to vote for one or the other
and i'm going to suggest that that's
what we should change
that we have to stop being bludgeoned
with the fact that here are your two
choices you haven't you you can't waste
your vote so don't vote for anyone else
if you had something like ranked choice
voting and open primaries then you could
vote for whoever you wanted and you
would see different perspectives start
to emerge that could legitimately
challenge the duopoly because the
duopoly is failing us on multiple fronts
i mean one is because
of the polarization and the fact that
now we're being pitted against each
other
but there's also no
need for them to really perform
[Laughter]
because you know that they don't have
any viable competition
yeah i you know i was going to save
discussion of
the forward party platform until the end
but it occurs to me that we can
bring it in here because i want to talk
about inequality and we can just get to
that when
you talk about that part of the platform
so let's just jump now to
uh the forward party and what how you
view it as a
a possible movement here that can
just ram through some of these
totally sane changes what's what's the
plan what's the aspiration and what's
the platform
so let's say that you've listened to
this and and thought wow we can actually
pass ballot initiative initiatives that
would dramatically improve the
incentives of half of our legislators
let's go do that which is certainly what
i thought
when i realized that it was possible
and in the other states it's still
possible too you would just need
conscientious legislators to pass it at
state houses which i'm going to suggest
is kind of a higher bar
in in some of these places
so
the
ballot initiative process in each state
it's highly variable in cost
it's less expensive in a place like
north dakota than it would be in
california
as you could imagine
but the resources necessary to get all
the signatures and promote and advertise
then try and get 50.1 percent of people
in that state to approve it
no it's significant i mean you're
looking at a real popular movement
and these are in red and blue states and
so i thought to myself
how can we most effectively galvanize
people around
these ballot initiatives and this vision
and
realize that it should be from outside
the duopoly which would probably make
perfect sense to people and
one of the
defining
phrases of my campaign was it's not left
or right it's forward
and so
i decided to start the forward party to
make these ballot initiatives happen to
give rise to open primaries and rank
choice voting in states around the
country to elevate candidates who
support this and existing officials
because they are out there
but also let people know that we don't
have to
suffer
in this dysfunction
any longer than we already have i mean
we can be
fixed on actually amending the
incentives of our broken system
so
i've launched the forward party
i'm super excited about it it does have
a number of other tenants aside from
open primaries and ranked choice voting
but that is really the first major step
in enabling any real
dynamism and competition in our
political system because what's fun sam
is people regard me as fairly rational
which i appreciate a great deal
and people regard third parties as not
rational
[Laughter]
and they regard third parties as not
rational because they say hey the
mechanics are set up in a way to make it
impossible
and
they have been
on the money for the last number of
years but
there is now this possibility for change
as demonstrated by what's happened in
alaska
and there is also this growing appetite
for
a real shift in our politics where the
number of americans that are now for a
third party
is at a record high
the last measure i saw was 62 percent so
think about that if you arrived in a
marketplace and there was a duopoly and
62 percent of people wanted something
new you'd want to offer it so that is
the forward party that is
our opportunity to actually move the
country in a better direction
well i can imagine the the first concern
in the minds of many democrats will be
that
if this movement
gained any steam at all
despite your best intentions it would
serve as some kind of spoiler principle
with respect to any
you know depending on the time frame
could be as early as next year but in
particular with respect to
a possible
presidential run in 2024 where trump is
once again on the ballot
what do you say to the possibility of
this is the absolute wrong time to be
considering
a third party
if your overriding
concern politically is to never see
trump in office again
some really fascinating articles came
out over this past week or so sam
that talk about the danger that trumpism
presents which i agree with
and it talks about the weakness in our
system where you can have one of two
major parties that is
overrun by bad leadership and then all
the incentives are to stay in line and
in a way that's kind of a weak and
vulnerable system you know it had
it had a fairly big opportunity for
someone like trump just to run roughshod
over one of the two major parties
the goal for all of us should be to make
the system itself more resilient from
authoritarianism
and the best way to do that would be to
adopt a more
vibrant multi-party system as quickly as
possible
and if you are a democrat and you see
this
one approach could be oh we must defeat
trump and you know i could totally get
it but another approach would be oh we
should make this system more resilient
from
any anyone that comes along including
trump
but maybe it's not just trump and to me
that should be where our energies are
directed
and that's
a challenge that we should be taking on
as quickly as possible is to try and
make the system genuinely more
resilient and representative and
multi-polar
if you look at other countries around
the world the uk has five parties sweden
has eight parties netherlands has 18
parties and if you have eight parties
and then one of them gets overrun by bad
leadership that's a problem but it's not
like an existential problem
you know what i mean whereas if you have
two major parties then it can be an
existential problem and unfortunately we
may be faced with that quite soon
so let's talk more about the platform
you propose and
the in particular the
human-centered capitalism
side of things and then the economics
because um
you know your
support for ubi falls squarely here
i think the
problem in need of remedy is
uncontroversial we have this
this widening inequality
in our society
you know which is not just economic but
economics is at the center of all of it
and there's just this disjunction
between
the gains and productivity we've seen in
recent decades and our quality of life
and you go through this
in the book but you know what's your
what's your view of the problem and
what would you propose to do about it
the united states is now 28th in the
world
in core measurements like infant
mortality clean air and clean water
public education freedom of speech
violence and crime
and these things are
the core markers of
where we are as a people and they're
getting worse
and
right now we're trumpeting and
cheerleading
stock market prices and gdp growth while
more and more americans feel like they
have no
relationship uh with
that version of the economy uh that's
driving trumpism in many environments
and
it's driving anger because people's
quality of life has been eroding for
years and decades
and so to me this should be the core
project of any government is to say how
the heck did the united states of
america with all its wealth and
resources allow itself to slip to 28th
in the world with a down arrow attached
to it
and if you were to start making
meaningful progress on those problems
then i think you would see
our health our mental health and our
political culture
improve
and you're seeing that in some measure
right now with the child tax credit and
some of the other
measures that have been implemented
where
about 70 million families well 70
million americans have been receiving
this child tax credit and you're already
seeing
better
ability to learn better health
the money is getting spent on exactly
what you hope it would be which is
nutrition and school supplies and
uh freeing up parents in some cases to
spend time with their children
so this is
the path forward that we should be
trying to build on
this
cash relief that's been going out and
obviously i'm a huge believer in
universal basic income
in part because i think that the
resources would be
better
spent
by people themselves rather than
administered by a bureaucracy
that would be paternalistic in many
cases
[Music]
sports have long been an important and
defining part of our history
with their impact and influence
key moments in sports have helped shape
heal
and inspire it has been said that i have
two alternatives
either go to jail
or go to the army
but i would like to say that there is
another alternative
that alternative is justice
i'm doc rivers and i'm proud to present
a new podcast documentary series called
it was said sports where i guide you
through six of the most impactful and
timeless speeches in sports history the
question has already been answered
should we be here
yes
listen and follow it was said sports a
documentary podcast presentation of
shining city audio a c13 originals and
john meacham studio available now
wherever you listen to your podcast
[Music]
it's interesting because the
the aid that the government has rolled
out
in response to the covet pandemic
you know it's not identical to ubi
obviously but it's importantly similar
as you point out and i think
many people
worry that what we've witnessed here
many people who are
fans of the concept of ubi
are worried that what we're witnessing
here is
kind of a failed
example of ubi
or a um
at least
showing some of the possible downsides
of ubi and i'm interested to know
what are the differences that would make
the difference here because i think we
have something like 10 million unfilled
jobs at this point and you hear
that the restaurant industry and and
other similar industries
can't find all the workers they need to
function
and so there's a picture of people
getting just enough money from the
government at this point where they can
decide
you know i i don't want that job anymore
and i'm and i i don't actually have to
take it and
i i you know i wonder whether there's
just uh you know if there's just a
further argument here for
improving wages and other you know other
variables but
it's not a
patently obvious picture of success when
you look at the knock-on effects to the
rest of the economy
well sam i think we should distinguish
between the child tax credit
which is having
extraordinarily positive results
according to let's say 448 economists
who just signed a letter saying we
should keep this going forever because
of
so many of the positive outcomes
and
the enhanced unemployment and other
programs that have almost certainly had
a an impact on what you're describing in
terms of the labor market and unfilled
jobs the problem is that in the latter
category we are attaching this money
to
your being unemployed
where where and i know young people who
are on this right now and they're
receiving
uh let's call it
five six hundred dollars
a week um on the condition that they are
not employed yeah
and so if you're in that position i've
talked to 25 year olds in this boat
they're looking at me being like hey
like obviously i'm just gonna like hang
out until
until this thing runs out
and you look at it would be like yeah
that's a rational behavior
but the problem really is and again it's
being tied to not working
yeah if that money were
let's say a little bit lower than 500
you know i think
in some cases it's a little higher than
you would be administering university so
if they were getting my plan of a
thousand bucks a month and by the way
they could keep it
on top of whatever they earned if they
decided to
take a job part-time full-time whatever
i think you'd see different behaviors
then here's money but you only get it if
you don't work
hmm
what about
some concerns around the
possible inflationary effect of this
kind of support i know larry summers has
been out there
worrying
quite um
volubly about
inflation in response to
how much money is being pumped into the
system and i i don't know if he's tied
it directly to
a conception of ubi proper but i could
imagine he would be worried about the
same effect
how does that stack up as a concern
or a reason why not to implement ubi
right now from what i've seen the
majority of the inflation has been
because our supply chain is messed up
and so if you can't get stuff
then the stuff you do get you end up
increasing the prices of in in various
ways
the vast majority of the money that's
gotten pumped into the economy
has not been to individuals and families
i think about 17 of the cares act went
into human beings hands and you know 83
went into various institutions
so to the extent we're seeing inflation
right now it's it's
being driven by disruptions uh in the
economy
from what from what i've seen
i'm someone who is very responsive to
data so if you were to do something and
you were to see
various effects then you know you might
want to calibrate
but i don't think it's because people
have
so much money to spend that they're
driving at prices it's that there's just
not enough stuff to go around
and so the stuff that is out there uh
goes up in price
yeah this there's this that other piece
you just flagged which is
how incompetently
all of this aid was administered there
certainly was an argument for certain
institutions being receiving money
rather than than individuals
but you know the bad incentives and just
the
incompetent execution and all the the
people who most needed money
couldn't
get it in many cases
i remember you know one of the selling
points of ubi from your point of view is
that
one thing the government is good at is
just cutting checks
but the truth is we don't even seem to
be that good at cutting checks at the
moment i mean we just we we don't have a
digitally native
truly agile way to just
get people money
you know tomorrow morning when when we
need to
we're using the irs
which has its ups and downs in terms of
a distribution pipe and i said in the
book how i talked to
ben bernanke
and he suggested that we give everyone a
fed account and then we could just put
the money in your account if we decided
it was a good idea um so we're using the
irs which is not designed for it it
misses a lot of people including a lot
of people at the low end to your point
sam who really needed the money because
if you're really poor a lot of the times
you don't file taxes you know you like
paid a bit
less than that
and
so
it's a real failure of the government on
a couple of fronts and the failure is
even worse when you look at some of the
tailored programs and i've been very
angry about this rental assistance
program that the government put
something like 67 billion dollars into
so in theory okay gonna help renter 67
billion dollars and then they checked
back eight months later and only 17 of
the money had actually been administered
by city and local governments because
the federal government had kind of left
it to the locality to figure out how to
get the renters the money and lo and
behold they didn't do it and so then you
have 2.6 million renters who
theoretically were supposed to get money
that didn't get money and are now
probably gonna get evicted in the rest
of it and when you see a colossal
failure like that on the part of
government
does anyone lose their job does anyone
you know get held accountable is anyone
like sorry of course not but you know
there are millions of americans that at
least theoretically were supposed to get
that money
so
it's one reason why i am a huge fan of
something like a ubi because we're still
exceptionally good at
sending money relative to the other
things that we claim to to want to do
for people
in a way the more you can simplify
things for government
the the
the the happier we'll be and the better
the results will be
all right so what is um what's the
future of the forward party what do what
can people do where can they they find
it you must have a website
what's the ask of my audience and any
other audience
well first if you do want to dig into
my experiences in terms of the system's
dysfunction and why we need to mend and
amend our political system please do
check out the book
for the argument for the forward party
it's called forward and then if you've
already heard enough and you want to
support the forward party uh go to
forwardparty.com or andrewyang.com
and let's build this movement together i
i know that this is the group that's
going to do it because the people that
follow sam
are students of reason
of rationality
not huge fans of tribalism
and this is exactly what we need to
build we need to build
a movement of people who just want to
solve the problems and believe in
universality believe that we are still
all
human beings at the end of the day
i'm going to ask the obvious question
which uh i think you you may be
reluctant to answer at this point but uh
don't let my telepathy uh push you
around too much
do you think you're gonna run for office
again
i'm going to do whatever i can to help
sam i'm certainly not someone and i
think you picked this up on me the first
time we met like i'm not someone who has
some kind of
deep-seated desire for political office
you know
there were aspects of running for office
that i
absolutely loved um and then there are
aspects that were
quite difficult
and so
i'm taking it day by day in terms of
figuring out how i can make the most
difference
but
we all know that our country's not doing
well and thanks to to you and some other
people i feel like i'm in a fairly
narrow group of individuals who might be
able to help so that's what i'll be
trying to do to the best of my ability
yeah yeah well you are
impressively networked at this point i
mean i can only imagine
and so it's
this is really not as
much of a pipe dream as it might seem to
anyone on the outside you know hearing
this for the first time i mean you you
know
you have a lot of friends
who have a lot of friends at this point
and you're about as plugged in as
as anyone
and it's
it certainly doesn't take all that many
people to raise a ton of money and it's
and it doesn't take all that many minds
in need of changing
to
to fundamentally birth a um
a new movement and a new direction we
might all take together
you know the number of minds that need
to change to fundamentally
change the direction and not only of our
country but of civilization
you know that's numbered in the
thousands right that's not we're not
talking about millions in the end
so anyway you you know some of these
people i know some of these people and
um
i'm rooting for you and uh however i can
be of help uh just uh let me know i'm
still waiting for that um
the uh celebratory uh meal when when uh
when you occupy some office somewhere so
whether or not it's you or or someone we
just mutually like it'll be fun when it
happens we're gonna have that meal my
friend we're gonna have that meal well
thanks again andrew good luck with the
book thank you so much sam
[Music]
you